and fulfilling it feels natural feel
some right
we're about to go into the Apple event
I've never been here before
I'm really excited to turn the ambush I
need to get that black and gold yeah I'm
saying trying a lot I think it's going
to be amazing
this is hostile right now it's beautiful
all these people are here just to show
us a staff is on hand to help you try
them on - heading ultimate experience so
already this feels amazing
I'm going to reply with an emoji that
changes the game from messaging I think
it's really a file and it's right on my
wrist that's so easy I love it feels
very classy it's almost kind of like
vintage like old Hollywood food a kind
of like a movie star mixed with an
astronaut not sure maybe a Power Ranger
a theory where's the closest Starbucks
nice thanks Siri I hope that I can draw
flowers like they did in the demo yeah
feel a little bit like a preschooler but
thank you
[ __ ] look at the look at the wrist it
feels good it feels not really there it
feels like a good watch it's a piece of
technology so you would think it might
be heavy if I'm like at a party and the
guys think super creepy I can just like
Tapan that will be like come save me
right now rescue me girlcode like taken
to the next I like that when you turn
the bullet comes up
in a simple kind of world and I really
like that it just gets the point across
that's what time it is
demo I was almost worried that it would
be a little bit tough to draft if it
seemed like there's so many things to do
it's really easy I like the way this one
feels a little bit heavier I'm a small
girl so that's kind of rough for me the
the leather ones feel good but this one
right here this feels like a man's watch
I don't like to see a man wearing this
one like Iron Man I think it's gonna
change the way that we talk to each
other before I was a little skeptical
about a lot but after seeing it in
action and wearing it I want it so badly
black and gold is my favorite the watch
is gorgeous it was an awesome experience